jetzt weiß ja niemand wann dieser Krieg
zu Ende sein wird aber soweit ist klar
die Ankündigung von Netanyahu steht im
Raum man wird Israel wird erstmal im
Gazastreifen bleiben und ihn weiter
kontrollieren könnte es bedeuten dass
die Menschen die jetzt im Gazastreifen
vom Norden in den Süden geflohen sind
auf absehbare Zeit gar nicht mehr
zurückkehren können in den
Norden was heißt absehbare Zeit das kann
sich im Zeitspanne von einigen Monaten
sicherlich halten langfristig gesehen
müssen diese Leute natürlich wieder in
den Norden zurückgehen Gaza City ist der
größte Ort im Gazastreifen äh
da leben rund eine Millionen Menschen
wenn ich mich nicht ganz täusche und
die Nachbarländer das ist das einzige
Nachbarland des Gasastreifen so gesagt
Ägypten möchte auf keinen Fall ä eine
größere Anzahl von Palästinenser
aufnehmen weil Ägypten auch fürchtet
dass die dann nie wieder äh äh nach Gaza
Schrägstrich Palästina zurückkören
können mm damit haben sie schon die
Frage aus äh von Youtube von SGE
beantwortet was ist eigentlich mit
Ägypten warum redet keiner darüber dass
sie keinen einzigen Flüchtling aufnehmen
es gibt noch eine zweitere Frage warum
will denn kein arabischer Staat
Verantwortung für Gaza übernehmen es
gibt ja auch das Szenario dass eben eine
Koalition von arabischen Staaten die mit
Israel verbündet sind eben im
Gazastreifen
eingreifen oder bzw die Kontrolle
übernehmen oder die Verwaltung wäre das
denn ein denkbares
Szenario ich glaube es ist aber nur
denkbar wenn es dazu eindeutiges
unomandat gibt und dann werden was
werden es wahrscheinlich auch
gemischte Truppen gemischte Verwaltung
mit Beteiligung von arabischen Staaten
aber natürlich auch von ganz anderen
Staaten auf der Welt wo die arabischen
Staaten bereit sind zu helfen und das
wurde immer wieder groß angekündigt
ist finanziell den Gasastreifen es gibt
sogar die Träume da davon oder die
Vision den gazazil Streifen zu einer Art
Dubai der Levante zu machen die
pertinens sind gut ausgebildet vor dem
gaserstreifen das vergisst man auch
immer wieder liegen große Öl und
Gasfelder wo Ägypten Israel und die
Palästinenser schon über deren
Ausbeutung gesprochen hatte dieses
nachgaser heißt natürlich vor allen
Dingen auch dass die
golfmonarchien für eine wirtschaftliche
Entwicklung dort einsetzen und Gaza zu
einem etwas ganz anderes machen als was
es heute ist einem großen freilicht gef
und da ist natürlich auch die
israelische Regierung gefragt da gibt es
aber auch Stimmen die wirklich wie
gesagt eindeutig sagen nach Hamas wenn
Hamas militärisch zerstört ist müssen
wir uns ganz malive Gedanken drüber
machen was wir in Gaza machen können um
endlich mal zu einer Friedensregelung
mit den Palästinensern zu kommen dazu
gibt's noch eine Frage von Kali wie
viele Jahrzehnte wurde eine zwei Staaten
Lösung versucht gibt es noch eine andere
Lösung also die zwei staatenlösung die
Idee entstand 1993 mit diesem so
hoffnungsvollen osloprzess und es gab
immer wieder Annäherungen es gab immer
wieder ein fast wirklichen Frieden und
dann haben Extremisten von beiden Seiten
den immer wieder zerstört
ähm es gibt glaube ich keine Alternative
zu der Zweistaatenlösung da ein einstaat
ähm die jüdische Identität Israels
gefährden würde im Sinne dass die
palästinensische Demografie immer weiter
wächst dass irgendwann diesem Staat mehr
me Palästinenser als Israelis leben
würden deshalb möchten auch die Israelis
nicht es wurden auch immer wieder über
eine konfederation gesprochen das heißt
eine lose Verbindung eben zwischen den
besetzten westjordland Gaza und Israel
aber das scheint auch sehr schwierig zu
sein da wie wie im Grunde würde das dann
schon auch wieder auf die zwei
staatenlösung herauslaufen das große die
krcks im Moment für die zwei
staatenlösung ist dass gerade unter dem
jetzigen israelischen Premierminister da
immens viele neu Siedlungen im besetzten
wer westj Land gegründet worden und es
natürlich sehr schwer sein wird für eine
israelische Regierung zu sagen wir
müssen auch hier wieder Siedler
Umsiedlern und
Siedler Siedlung den palästinensn
zurückgeben also ist ein sehr harariger
Prozess aber meiner Ansicht nach der
einzige realistische und vielleicht hat
ja dieser Bar barische wegruf durch der
das hamasattentat
in gewisserweise Wirkung gezeigt dass
ähm z.B usamerikanische Regierung wieder
intensiv die zwei staatenlösung auf den
Tisch gebracht hat mhm ma rosa hat noch
mal eine Nachfrage zu den Siedlern sie
sagt es wurde gesagt einer zwei
staatenlösung stehen die Siedlungen im
Weg warum kann die warum kann man die
israelischen Siedlungen nicht räumen
lassen fragt sie ja gut das würde
natürlich innenpolitischen Israel gerade
un der jetzigen Regierung für enormen
Widerstand äh äh Widerstand sorgen ähm
noch ist diese israelische Regierung an
der Macht man kann sich fragen wie lange
aber in dieser israelischen Regierung
sind ä zum Teil rechtsextreme ähm
sehrrechte äh die total äh in der
Siedlerbewegung sind und diese auf
keinen Fall zulassen würden und yatanao
brauchte diese rechten politischen
Parteien um überhaupt an der Macht zu
bleiben äh wird es jetzt eine liberale
oder eine Koalitionsregierung eine
Regierung der Mitte geben äh wo man halt
über das nachchamas den nachkrieg
nachdenkt könnte es sein dass einige
Siedlungen geräumt werden gerade
Siedlungen die sehr isoliert sind oder
gerade Siedlungen die quasi
palästinensische Städte voneinander
abschneiden aber das steht noch in
weiter Sterne im Moment sind wir leider
in diesem sehr bedauerlichen Krieg
Sebastian schreibt eine dauerhafte
Besatzung ist nicht sinnvoll kostet
Menschenleben und Material und würde
Israel finanziell Schwächen
ja genau das ä das ist es auch so und
deshalb wurde auch ä ä das das
Statement des Premierministers heute in
Israel so so schlecht aufgenommen im
Moment hat die Israel durch ä die
generalmobilmachen 400.000 Soldaten
400.000 Soldaten in einem 10 Millionen
Land
in dem
auch Menschen einfach nicht zur Armee
gehen können das heißt z.B die
arabischen Israelis und auch äh die
orthodoxen
Juden ä nicht whfleächtig sind ist sind
400.000 Menschen enorm gerade in der
israelischen Armee und eine große
Belastung eine besatzunggasa ist eine
wirkliche besatzungsgasa ist würde
ständig 10taus von Truppen nach Ansicht
von militärspezialisten binden und auch
das ist natürlich ein sehr hoher Preis
und auch ein sehr gefährlicher Preis den
ein Großteil der israelischen
Gesellschafts natürlich nicht zahlen
möchte und deshalb dann auf
Lösung in Lösung entweder durch
Übernahme der palästinensischen
Autorität in Gaza oder eben eine
Internationalisierung durch die UNO
hofft vielleicht zum Schluss die Frage
also Netanyahu hat ja bis jetzt nicht
die politische Verantwortung für das
übernommen was am 7 Oktober passiert ist
mit ihm ist der Krieg in den
Gazastreifen gekommen ist er der
richtige Mann kann es mit ihm
dauerhaften Frieden geben in der Region
irgendwann
ähm das glauben vor allen Dingen auch
die Israel nicht die die Israelis sich
für Frieden einsetzen würden das glauben
natürlich auch die Araber mittlerweile
nicht weil er man muss auch immer denken
die größte Mitschuld an an dem im
Versagen der israelischen Militärs an
diesem schrecklichen barbarischen der
diesen schrecklichen barbarischen
Anschlag der Hamas möglich gemacht hat
lag an jatanau selber er hat er hat
Hamas jahrelang geduldet um die
Palästinenser zu schwächen um sie zu
spalten er hat die Finanzierung von
Hamas also indirekt von Hamas also die
Finanzierung der palästenser ähm im im
Gazastreifen durch Katar überwacht
geschehen lassen und da kann ich mir
kaum vorstellen dass
heute jemand
also fast alle Israelis gehen davon aus
dass J nicht an der Macht bleibt und
dass die Frage gar nicht stellt ob mit
diesem Mann überhaupt eine
Friedenslösung los ist
ist dass sich vermutlich um Wochen oder
vielleicht Monate handelt bis eine neue
israelische Regierung an die Macht kommt
bisher hat kein israelischer
Premierminister eine militärische
Niederlage oder ein eine solcherheit
Sicherheitsgefahr als
als
als in der Politik überlebt Herr LD frui
ich danke Ihnen sehr für das Gespräch
ich bedanke mich tschüss bedanke mich